Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Today!
Today is our 92nd episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Wow, I see some new Ruffians.
What to explain about FUWAMOCO Morning?
It's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
You still a little bit froggy there, huh?
Kero kero!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I ain't done!
A different doggy froggy maybe?
A doggy frog year!
I ain't doggy frog year!
Yeah.
Compare it.
Today!
Howl!
It's a little foggy.
Well, it's a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
And unfortunately... There's been another Pero Sighting.
Well, let's see.
Let's take a look.
Hope for the best.
De-den!
At the airport!
Pero, he is awfully happy to be there at the airport with you!
Sharing a chair.
Oh, like, nice.
He's having a nice conversation together.
Yeah, I don't know, Ruffians.
Something's a little bit funny here.
But those puppy eyes too!
Yeah, you're being too nice to him, huh?
You know.
I can tell that he can use you, you know, this Ruffian to the advantage, right?
Yeah, make sure you're careful, okay?
Careful!
We told you lots and lots of Ruffians, but yet, when you see Pero, you're still getting pretty close to him.
You have to stay away.
Yeah, but you took him to Singapore with you!
Why?
Hopefully he's not up to...
BAU!
Maybe we have a peril whisperer or something.
We hope you had an amazing time at G-House 3.
It sounds like it was the concert of a lifetime.
I want to check it out live!
BAU BAU!
You sound like one of the creatures you find in Australia, no?
BAU BAU Ruffians!
There has been so many amazing things going on that I...
FUWAMOCO, uh, we feel a little bit bad because we're a bit behind on reporting them to you here on FUWAMOCO Morning.
Right.
Well, we can't keep up.
We'll catch up now.
Yeah.
Well, whole album's demono sound Nerissa waving claws!
She just released her first original song, Say My Name!
BAU BAU BAU!
Nerissa!
Nerissa K. Yeah, Nerissa K. N-E-R-I-S-S-A.
K. No!
Nerissa K. BAU!
It's so amazing!
This sounds so good!
It's so disco-y and swanky and snazzy.
It just really captures everything that makes up
Nerissa waiting for time.
Not just the song though, the video is so beautiful too.
It's an alluring animation of Nerissa dancing and slaying.
Not just once.
Not just twice.
Not just three times.
Not just four times.
I'm not just Faitan, I'm not just Fuwamoco-chan.
I'm not just Faitan, I'm not just Fuwamo
Listen to it lots again!
And Nerissa!
Congratulations on your first original song!
BAU BAU!
And also, Nerissa hit a big milestone on YouTube too!
Nerissa hit a milestone that she wanted to reach of 669,000 subscribers!
Wow!
And she did it!
BAU BAU!
Well done, Nerissa!
Congratulations!
Let's continue to all do our best together, okay?
Yeah!
Advent strong!
BAU BAU!
Yay!
I don't know, usually most like at 100 you celebrate it, right?
Or like at the 50 you celebrate it, right?
I guess the number wasn't pointing to her.
I mean, 2-2-2 is special to us, right?
But, speaking of Advent, not only has Nerissa had some especially cool things going on, but Advent are clever!
Shiori Novella also has had a bunch of things going on too!
Shiori also hit a huge milestone!
She reached 500!
10,000 subscribers on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
And not just that!
This week is Shiori's birthday too!
Her first birthday since her debut!
Her birthday is on May 2nd!
May 6th is not too far from now, and she'll be celebrating it together with the novelies and a big birthday party!
Yeah, baths!
Birthday baths!
It's not a birthday party, it's a birthday bath!
I almost said birthday bath.
Not a birthday bath!
Yeah, there'll be so many fun activities and things that Shiori's been planning!
Cake!
Oh, cake!
You think so?
Shiori!
Happy birthday!
I do, I do, Shiori.
BAU BAU!
So many exciting advent anniversaries?
Anniversaries?
Advent... milestones?
Advent times.
Advent times, yeah.
Oh, you mean this!
Got it!
Not tomorrow, but the day after tomorrow!
Not tomorrow, what?
Not the day after tomorrow.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Oh, we're not late on this one.
No.
This is brand new information, so listen up, okay?
Yeah.
Just a few hours ago, a new voice pack was released, and FUWAMOCO will participate in it!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's the Mysterious Preschool Voice Pack!
Yeah!
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO!
This time Moco-chan, you became a preschooler, and I became a preschool teacher!
But some Ruffians might know, but I really couldn't stop laughing while we were doing the recording.
Yeah.
You know that day, I was super stuffed up.
So badly.
My nose wouldn't stop running and I just couldn't stop sneezing the whole time.
It's never been like that.
It was really strange.
Yeah.
So, I really got into the role of the snotty little preschooler.
Definitely, yeah.
Yeah.
So, Ruffians, if you listen closely, do you need to listen closely?
If you take a listen, I think you can definitely tell just how stuffed up Moco-chan was.
Well, you can enjoy both the worlds of taking care of a needy Moco-chan, tiny Moco-chan, and, uh,
Also being babied.
Babied by a big chihuahua.
There's a voice back too.
We've already been seeing how much you've been doing it, Ruffians.
The Ruffians have been getting a little bit silly.
10 out of 10!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Like usual, we also recorded it in both English and Japanese, so please check them both out, and you can enjoy the little differences between the two, too.
Yeah, you still have any quiet yet?
Mada kattenai?
Just get to sleep!
Ima da yo!
BAU BAU!
Please check it out, okay?
It was really fun.
There's samples as well.
Yeah, you can check out on the hololive official store, official shop.
You can check out the voice pack samples.
You can listen up to a minute.
Right.
So, please check it out, okay?
It's a long sample, okay?
Yeah, in both English and Japanese.
BAU BAU!
Well, yesterday was also a really big day for FUWAMOCO.
Because, well, we had our first collab and off-collab with Mighty Senchou Senpai!
BAU BAU!
We were really nervous because of the off club.
We got to go and barge into Morning in Senchou-senpai's place.
And this time we played the classic game series Touhou's Mountain of Fate together.
And Senchou-senpai taught us some very good strategies.
She taught us
Her pro skills.
Yeah.
And if you didn't know, Ruffians, Marine-senpai, she's known for just her amazing, amazing, not just, but her amazing professional.
Yeah, her professional play.
I know, it's really mesmerizing watching her, but I think her biggest shock though was the moment she pulled out a controller!
Because we always thought that wasn't an option.
Yeah!
It was a keyboard game!
Yeah, she plays on controller, not keyboard!
You know, we thought that's the only way you could play Touhou, but on keyboard, that was the way to play it!
Yeah!
We still have a lot to learn, huh?
Yeah.
When did that happen?
Yeah, but, you know, it was until we cleared the whole mountain of faith, but even though we had so much fun, we still weren't quite able to beat the game completely.
The last boss gonna play the Ruffian.
So, you know, FUWAMOCO, we'll just have to practice lots and lots so that Senchou-senpai will be proud of us and then maybe we can show her just how much we've improved too!
Yeah!
And, uh...
It's a little bit embarrassing, but during our collab, I-I finally did it!
I convinced Mari-senpai!
That you know that she's my OC!
You really like Mari-senpai, right?
I like her too much.
I know.
I can't help it, she's so cute and cool and so talented and just...
But hopefully you know, FUWAMOCO, maybe one day we can become an amazing member of hololive just like her someday too.
But not only did we just play Touhou together, but we also had sukiyaki for dinner too!
We didn't eat her food.
No.
We had dinner together!
And you know, it was just so nice being able to chat and take it easy together.
We chatted so much, oh my gosh.
Time flew by fast.
Oh my god, a little bit dangerous there.
I lost track of time.
But you know, during dinner,
My nose wouldn't stop running, so I was trying to get out of my handkerchief, but Mighty-senpai gave me a tissue before I could find it!
Tissue!
But it was funny, because it smelled really good!
It was almost like a...
Dangerous Mining Smell.
Moco-chan, why didn't you let me smell it too, huh?
Because you have my snot in you.
I don't know, it's kind of funny how things are like that, right?
We just had such a good time together.
We really hope that we can get to know my Senchou Senpai a lot more in the future too!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, I'm not gonna share the message that I sent Senchou Senpai afterwards.
Did Mococo keep the tissue?
That's what I was asking!
Moco-chan, do you still have the tissue?
Is it in your bag?
Can I smell it?
It has my snot in it.
Moco-chan, where is it, huh?
Threw it out.
Why?
Well, technically, it's at the restaurant.
In their garbage.
So they have it, huh?
They have it.
I think it's probably gone now, huh?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Well, also, Ruffians!
You know, with this week being the big roll that we call it is in Japan, FUWAMOCO, we've been doing a bunch of JP's twos!
And special collabs with our JP-senpai, like Koyori-senpai, and Marine-senchou-senpai, so fun!
But...
You might have noticed something new too.
Ruffians!
Well, you know, we had to peddle down and ask him if he could help us out with something important.
Oh well.
Oi!
Did you notice?
Yo, FUWAMOCO, you know, we know there's a number of Ruffians who are still just starting the Japanese language journey and that you really, really want to enjoy our streams and Japanese live together with us too!
So, FUWAMOCO, we begged and begged Pero to help us by doing some live translating from Japanese to English during our streams!
Amazing, right?
Yeah, you know, usually he's very nasty, but this time... He decided to be a little sweet for you Ruffians.
Just for the Ruffians, huh?
The name is a bit different, huh?
BAU BAU!
But we really hope that that's helped you enjoy things a little bit more together with us so far this week!
But we're still doing streams in English at our usual times this week like always though!
So if maybe you can't stay up until the middle of the night to be there live for the streams, don't worry!
You can also check the live chat on the archive for Peron's translations too!
I guess as for when Pero will show up next door, we're not too sure.
I guess whenever he can.
But we hope it'll be often though.
We know there were some very kind Ruffians who would do the live translation for us as well.
But really, we don't want to put pressure on you.
We want you to be able to enjoy the streams as well.
Of course, you know, we're super appreciative of all your help as well.
And, uh, who knows, you know?
Maybe we might need it again sometime in the future, too!
Okay!
Thank you so much, everyone!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, too, pal.
Yeah, I guess.
BAU BAU!
If only that time
I guess it's the middle of the week, huh?
It's the middle of the week, Ruffians!
How has the week been going for you?
Japan has Golden Week!
But you probably don't have a holiday week right now too, right?
Do you need a little bit of some pop?
Maybe?
Moco-chan.
Is it okay if... I do a pup talk this time?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time of the week again!
It's time for a Mococo pup talk!
But this time...
It's a Fuwawa Pup Talk!
So that means you're going to hear it straight from me!
Fuwawa!
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
How have you been holding up this week so far?
Has it been a little more rough than usual?
But, you're doing your absolute best!
I know it!
So, please hang in there.
Don't let things get you down.
And just take each moment as it comes, you know?
And hopefully, you can count on Moco-chan and I to protect your smile during the really rough times too.
Okay?
I know, there are probably a bunch of things that you're putting off too, right?
You know, those things that no one wants to do.
The important things.
I know, I feel that way too.
I know you work hard, you want to have fun when it's time to have fun.
But let's do them together and then we'll get them out of the way!
And that means that we can have even more fun together when it's time to have fun.
Okay?
I believe in you!
So do your best, okay?
I'm cheering for you!
And I'll be here to give you a little push when you need it too.
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
How did I do, Moco-chan?
I'll do my best next time then too.
BAU BAU!
Well, we'll take a look at a regular cornice from you Ruffians!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
RGOS is super cuddly and fuzzy!
RGOS, you know, he's very silly amongst Kami-Rums.
Fuzzy and cuddly and silly.
Waggles can have the looky.
How do you think Oracle's BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
I don't know if I can do a very good job today, but the best I was.
BAU BAU!
I look super cute with those big ears and puppy dog eyes.
And nose that makes you want to go boop to it too.
And it sounds like he has also very good manners.
I think we all know that summer's just around the corner too, so we hope that you play in the water with him lots soon!
BAU BAU!
Have fun!
Bye ghosts!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
Hi!
Wow, Ruffians!
You've still been going on lots of walks, right?
Let's see which walks you've been going on.
What walks?
Which walks?
Where you been going?
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Osaka Castle!
This is the view from the very top.
What an adventure!
We hope you make sure to take a good break and get something yummy to eat afterwards.
Yeah, maybe a bunch of takoyaki!
Right!
Get that energy back!
Take a couple octopus legs and put them in your tummy.
Make sure it's not too hot, doggy.
You'll burn your mouth.
Well, we hope you continue to have lots of fun adventures around Japan, okay?
BAU BAU!
Next for our Question of the Day, we received Nerden!
Nyahalo, FUWAMOCO!
Now that you've obtained and tested a dual-stream PC setup, is there anything in particular that you're really excited about trying, or are you still theorycrafting and looking for ideas on it?
Thanks for all your hard work!
BAU BAU BAU!
Well, I think what we're looking forward to the most right now
Moco-chan.
Minecraft!
You know, it's been something that we really wanted to get into and just haven't been able to yet.
So we're really looking forward to being able to play it together and explore all together with you Ruffians.
We'll really need your help.
It's a little bit intimidating.
A lot.
A lot intimidating.
But we're still very much looking for ideas and suggestions also.
Let us know, okay?
There's a lot of games that I'm sure would be perfect for the both of us to play, but we just don't know about them.
There are some limits.
We tried a bunch of stuff.
Team Fortress 2.
I don't know it.
There's a lot of different things, but we really want to experiment and try everything we can.
But we can't do split screen.
We tried.
That's not something that will work.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions, your questions, your doggies, your books, and your Pero Sightings!
Please continue to send them to us with the hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Okay?
Ruffians!
Your part of FUWAMOCO Morning, a very important part, so please do yourself a meeting, oki?
We're waiting, oki!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream that we have coming up, we have De-den!
Super chat meeting!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you so much!
All the time.
FUWAMOCO We really wanna read them!
We just have not had enough time to be able to chat all together.
And Moco-chan, your bark is not barking the best right now too.
Really?
You think so?
You think I sound funny right now?
But we're gonna chat.
I haven't heard that one yet.
We're gonna chat as much as we can chat with Nerissa, right Moco-chan?
So we hope that you'll be there.
And once your barkers bark you like normal, then we'll spend a ton of time chatting, okay Ruffians?
We're really looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
And if we take another peek at our schedule here, there's so much!
Where do we start?
First we start!
After our super chat reading later!
Wonderful company's back together with Fubuki-senpai and Koyori-senpai and us!
And we're playing Lethal Company!
It was so much fun last time!
We got into a whole bunch of silly business.
But this time, Fuwawa, I'm gonna be playing too in my own steam.
It'll be split-screen again.
Not split-screen.
Ah, not split-screen.
Dual screens.
Funny business.
Help me up, okay?
BAU BAU!
After that too, we're also going to be playing content learning together with Haachama-senpai for the very first time!
And Pororo-neechan.
And Pororo-neechan, but it'll be really fun playing together with them and trying to make viral videos!
I have no doubt in their viral-ability skills.
So, let's do our best to make sure that we're a good addition to our production team, okay?
And those are the next teams coming up!
BAU BAU!
Please also join us for our Minecraft journey!
Yeah!
Lots of fun stuff coming up!
And for VALVians who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO-ed word!
It's BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU boys!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
BANMAN TAMAMO BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
YUMMY!
MOFUKURO!
BAU BAU!
ZAGLIER!
ACARIAN!
BAU BAU!
ALPHAGUS!
Tom.
BAU BAU!
Mifu.
Gertrude.
BAU BAU!
Mr. Fujisawa.
Exumabrain.
BAU BAU!
iDestiny.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!